翻訳: Shinnosuke Kinoshita
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
皆さんは 自分の生まれ故郷が
過疎化や少子高齢化で
いつか寂れていくかもしれないということを
想像したことはありますか？
もしそうなったら 寂しいなという気持ちに
なるのではないでしょうか
今日は 私の生まれ故郷である
山間の街を元気づけるために行った
小さなアイデアについてお話しします
浜松市に佐久間町という地域があります
浜松駅から60㎞ほど北上した
愛知や長野との県境に位置する地域です
私は その佐久間にある
浜松湖北高校佐久間分校の野球部に所属し
マネージャーとして
選手の練習のサポートをしています
さて 皆さんは佐久間に対して
どのようなイメージを持っているでしょうか
最高気温が高い地域として
名前を聞く人もいるでしょう
気温の高さは 暑さで電車が
遅延してしまうほどです
佐久間は このような豊かな自然に囲まれ
野生動物も活発に活動しています
日常生活の中でシカやサル
イノシシ ウサギなどの生き物に
遭遇することもあります
夏には川が私たちの最高の遊び場となります
私は この佐久間に住んでいることを
誇りに思っています
しかし 自然に囲まれている
佐久間ならではの問題もあります
電車は３時間に１本しか来ない時もあり
最寄りのコンビニは車で20分先にあります
毎年 地域内の店も
少しずつ少なくなっており
最近では 行きつけの書店も
お店をたたんでしまいました
佐久間は山間地域です
市の中心部から遠距離にあり
人口流出 少子化 高齢化が著しく
過疎地域に定められてしまいました
沢山の自然に囲まれている代わりに
無視できない側面も抱えています
そんな佐久間にある
唯一の高校が 佐久間分校です
ちょうど私が入学する時に 佐久間高校から
佐久間分校へと変わりました
全校生徒は69人と とても少ないですが
一人一人がそれぞれに輝ける
学校だと思っています
でも「分校」というと
あまりいい印象はないかもしれません
例えば 佐久間の隣町である愛知県の高校は
分校化してから３年で
廃校となってしまいました
近くの地域でそのようなことがあったので
佐久間で唯一の高校が
分校化することに対して
地域の人も寂しさを
感じているようにも見えました
その様な状況の中で佐久間分校野球部は
元気のなくなった地域を
盛り上げたいと考えました
高校野球は 夏の選手権大会で勝つと
校歌を歌うことができます
そこで 夏の大会でたくさんの人に
校歌を歌ってもらうことができるようにと
選手は日々練習に取り組んでいます
私は 選手のように直接グランドに立って
相手校と戦うことはできないし
練習をして技術を習得し
試合で活躍をするということもできません
しかし 選手のように
佐久間を盛り上げたい
という気持ちは一緒です
私もマネージャーとして
佐久間を盛り上げるということに
何か関わることはできないかと考えました
私はまず 地域の方と野球部が
つながれるきっかけを作ろうと考えました
野球部が勝って盛り上がってもらうには
まず 野球部について知ってもらうことが
大事なのではないかと考え
通学路の商店街に看板を設置しました
看板に書く内容は
試合の結果 学校で行う練習試合のお知らせ
選手の紹介などです
今の時代 多くの人に情報を伝えるときには
SNSで拡散するのが一般的になっています
しかし 私がここで選んだのは
看板を立てて情報を伝えるということでした
その理由のひとつは 地域には高齢者が多く
SNSでは伝わりにくいと思ったからです
その他にも 手書きには
温かみがあると思ったし
看板がおしゃべりの話題の
ひとつとなってくれたら
嬉しいなと思ったからです
この看板は 週に一度のペースで
更新をしています
私は 全くSNSで情報を
出していなかったので
この看板のことは
佐久間に在住している方にしか
広まっていないと思っていましたが
看板を置かせてもらっているお店の方が
更新をする事に SNSに
上げてくださっていました
そのおかげで
自分の予想以上に野球部のことを
たくさんの人に
知ってもらうことができました
看板を設置して様々な変化がありました
一番反響があったと感じるのは
学校で行う練習試合のお知らせをしたことです
看板を置く前よりも試合の時に
グランドに足を運んでくれる方が増えました
また 看板を出した事により
野球部に興味を持ってくれる人も増えました
看板を見るために商店街まで
足を運んでくれる人もいたそうです
学校の通学路に設置したことにより
在校生や中学生も野球部のことに
興味を持ってくれたようでした
たくさんの人が野球部のことに
関心を持ってくれるようになったので
選手のみんなも試合の結果に
こだわるようになったようにも感じました
看板を設置してよかったことは
他にもたくさんあります
今年の夏の大会のことも看板で伝えました
夏の大会は焼津球場で行われました
佐久間から焼津まではとても遠く
また 大雨の影響によりに電車が止まり
主要道路も通行止めとなっていました
しかし 球場のスタンドには たくさんの
地元の方が足を運んでくれていました
私は その試合でベンチに入っていたので
試合中のスタンドの様子は
分かりませんでしたが
試合終了後にスタンドを見ると
たくさんの知っている顔で埋められていました
それを見た時に とても感動しました
今 日本には少子高齢化が進行し
過疎地域となってしまった
町や地域が増えています
そのような地域に人を戻すこと
昔のように 栄えていた地域に戻すことは
難しく かなわないかもしれません
しかし 看板設置のような小さな行いが
地域の人々を元気づける
小さなきっかけとなるかもしれません
私は この地域のつながりはこれからも
大切にしていきたいと思っています
今後も野球部の今を伝え続けていきます
（拍手）